[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show we're
dead is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host rachel cruz
best-selling author ramsey personality
and my daughter is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your life
your relationships your work your career
even mental health stuff and certainly
money questions the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
thanks for calling in triple eight eight
two five five two two five margaret's
gonna start off this hour in minneapolis
hi margaret how are you
i'm all thank you
good how can we help
i have a question about baby step four
i understand i'm supposed to save 15 of
my income for retirement but this is our
situation i work part time i make 80 000
and my husband is retired
and
he takes he needs to take rmd
and social security so he makes fifty
thousand
do i save fifty percent of our total
income
or
just on my 80 000.
margaret that'll be yeah on your
on your total income how old are you
guys
i am 61 and my husband is 73.
okay and you said you work part-time
making 80
yes nice part-time job margaret say way
to go
what do you do
[Music]
i'm a physical therapist
for you good for you you built your
career up fabulously
to be able to to be able to monetize it
that way i'm proud of you excellent job
here's the thing all we're saying is is
is it smarter to save more or save less
the answer is almost always save more
the only problem is i'd love to save
money and i could put in
you know my whole
all my money with ross and health
savings accounts and the 403 b and the
457
and i guess i'd like permission to start
like doing
home repairs replace my culture that
we've had before we were married it's
like well i mean the reason to say the
reason to save money is have a
comfortable retirement
and so okay and you've already got one
of you there
yes so i mean if you want to save a
little less and you think you're going
to be comfortable
that's okay
but generally rachel's answer is we
generally just go yeah your household
income whatever the source is but you're
kind of like one foot on the boat and
one foot on the retirement boat and one
foot on the dock where we still work and
the boat's not left yet so you can do
either one you know you can go either
direction i don't
i think you're going to be okay is the
way i think i'm hearing this how much
money you got in
uh your investments now
um
depending on the day but 800 plus
thousand and retirement accounts yeah so
you're a millionaire way to go kiddo so
i think you're gonna be okay i mean you
don't think you're gonna mess this up
either way are you
no because i don't know that i'll ever
retire because i'm a
farmer's starter and farmers never
retire well there's not many 90 year old
pt's so eventually you'll back off of it
cool correct and i yes it is
labor-intensive
yeah it is it's hard work farmer's
daughter so look at you you're amazing
you're a rock star kiddo so yeah i you
know you you're a millionaire do you
have to save more no you don't have to
save more if you want to save more you
can so you can figure it on either one
and we're going to call you having one
okay touchdown way to go
you just won but the the floor is that
15 percent
that that's the lowest at that point
though in in general yes but i mean at
retirement do you say 15 when you're
both retired you say 15 of your
investment income off of the money
you've saved your 15 percent no no but
she's 61
making 80 000 working part-time 50 of
hers would be a minimum yes yes that's
what it was yeah i will misunderstood
yeah yes but 15 a household in general
that's fair 99 of the time we get this
question i don't know if i've ever
answered that question that way yeah 99
of the time it would be 15 of your
household income just shut up and do it
yes you know because that's going to get
you to where margaret is
that's the whole idea baby steps
millionaire right way to go man so cool
david is in albuquerque david what's up
how are you doing we want to say thank
you so much for everything you guys do
around you first of all thank you how
can we help
yeah apologize a little bit to cali
because when she first called i was so
excited she picked up i missed david my
question but it's pretty close okay um i
just ended baby step two i'm working on
baby step three
and i'm thinking i had to babysit 3b to
save her house and like i'm getting
stuck because i got my credit card still
over because i have a high credit score
and i don't know am i supposed to close
them
or keep them open to keep the credit
score up till i buy a house
that's a great question confused yeah
it's a great question and i feel like
it's it's a topic that we tackle a lot
because
there has been this mindset right in our
culture that the credit score is
everything right and so in order to buy
a house you have to have a great credit
score if you want to have a great life
you have to have a great credit score so
if you remove debt from your life if you
close all your credit card accounts
which we do recommend by the way
and you say okay i'm done with debt
completely what happens well over 12 to
18 months your credit score is going to
go down to undetermined it's going to
basically go you're gonna watch it just
go down down down but here's the deal
the only reason you need a credit score
is to go into debt and so we don't
believe in going to debt anymore because
you're debt free but for a mortgage it
is the one type of debt we won't yell at
you for but you can get a mortgage
actually without a credit score so it's
a process called manual underwriting so
you have to be current on your job for
two years and you have to be current on
all of your bills so you have to have
evidence of you know everything from
electricity or cell phone just proof
that you pay bills on time for two years
and a mortgage company churchill
mortgage is one that we recommend but
they will actually underwrite you the
mortgage without a credit score but the
danger is is that if you're going into
this
they will pull your credit score when
you go to take out a mortgage so you do
have to make sure that it's the point
because if it is if it is a bad credit
score right not undetermined but it is
lowering they can pull that and that
will ding you so you do have to get to a
point where your credit score is not is
undetermined basically
and then they can start that process of
manual underwriting and the detail is
you have to have every single account
closed and a zero balance
a zero balance and it has to be closed
otherwise it's still showing his
activity and so it's still plugging into
the fico score algorithm and it's going
to create a score
um and so if like if you have one
account open and all the rest are closed
and it is zeroed you're going to show a
low score your your score's going to
drop and you don't want to do that and
so if you go well i'm just going to keep
this one well you're going to screw up
this whole idea so it's kind of an all
or nothing you either need to keep them
all open and keep playing the game the
way the culture does and the culture is
broken stupid or you can play the game
where you go all the way
game on scorched earth no credit score
no borrowing money except for a house
and we're doing manual underwriting and
every single account has to be closed
and a zero balance and it will take at
least six months after that for your
credit score to be
undeterminable or indeterminable or i
just like saying zero i know because
it's not zero you do say that i know but
i'm a zero it's not zero i'm a zero and
you're a zero you're undetermined zero
no it's not
zero working
we have no identity we don't exist
because we have zero no it is not a zero
credit card there's no such thing as a
zero credit score undetermined
it means i don't exist
that's what it means i don't really live
off the grid i'm a hologram
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five
paying off debt is smart
saving and investing
is smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that people overlook all the time
and that's the defense side protecting
your finances
and that's where insurance comes into
play it's one of the areas you can do
for defense you have to do offense and
defense to win the game now 10 kinds of
insurance coverage you might need based
on what your life looks like and we
built a tool called the coverage checkup
it's completely free and it'll show you
which types you need to add drop or
adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance based on your
situation email it to you and connect
you with a ramsey trusted insurance
provider that'll shop and get you the
best deal anywhere really fast on that
type of insurance that you do need and
you're going to see some insurances you
probably need to drop that you're
getting ripped off on so seriously could
be really valuable five minutes you
spend right now
donald wrote in and he says i like and i
do like how he put it he said
for anyone who's not completed this
checkup do it right now you never know
when something will happen and you never
want to leave your family in a bad
situation that's exactly right
so check it out ramsey solutions dot com
slash check up it is a free
insurance checkup the coverage checkup
at ramseysolutions.com
emergencies aren't really emergencies we
pretty much know they're coming we just
don't know when
they're not really unexpected an
unexpected event is something you'd
never expect to happen but uh things
like that happen all the time and that's
why we need to
uh
go that direction open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jared is with us in minneapolis hi jared
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well we have
completed most of the baby steps we are
now max funding 15
between our roth 401k through work and
our roth ira and we have some money my
wife needs a new car
our household income is 160 000 a year
um and we are ready to pay about 25 000
cash for a new car for her good
however that being said the used car
market is ridiculous right now agreed
and
for example i just out of curiosity put
in an order on a ford pickup truck it's
like the little ford maverick
i built that for 22 grand
and it's going for 35 grand used on the
used market right now
so i'm just wondering
are we in a situation where it might be
acceptable to buy new if you've got the
cash for it rather than buy used
because i'm going to reap several
benefits just from warranties it never
being driven by somebody else
and all that yeah i mean the reason for
our no new car rule before you have a
million dollar net worth is because you
can't take
the hit when you drive it off the lot
right how much it loses in value but now
it's the only time i can remember so i'd
be so curious
that no and you're right jared my
husband and i we were looking for new
car and we even kelly blue booked our
van we bought a new van in 2019 we can
sell it today
for two thousand dollars more than what
we paid for it in 2019 like
it's bizarre so
in my opinion i mean if it's if it's
cheaper but can you get the truck though
that's the thing is that we're looking
at you're not going to get that truck
dude well it'll take four months it has
a build data april 18th yeah it has a
build date but you haven't talked to the
dealer yet about how much they're going
to market up above msrp
because yeah there's
dumping all these msrps all over the
place just make sure you get solid
numbers though but here's the deal
though
you have it in writing in writing
something they're not going to do that
which uh
how contested they do um either they do
bump it up and it'd still be worth less
than
what it would be used yeah so what's
your net worth
uh probably 100 000 right now we're both
24.
we are debt free so here's the thing
you know you can do this here's the
danger if you do it all right the danger
is number one i don't think that this is
going to fly i don't think it's going to
work because the the
all the people i'm talking to in the car
business are marking up everything
and so i don't know that you're going to
take delivery on this like you think
you're going to you might
it might be you might pull it off
um in which case you could sell it the
next day for a ten thousand dollar
profit
and so that just sounds a little wack to
me doesn't it to you
you know generally speaking in my life
if something sounds too good to be true
it's because it is
so that's a problem that bothers me here
the second thing is this
i don't want you to get in the habit of
asking the wrong question
right and the wrong question is how can
i figure out a way
to
violate a proven system towards wealth
and still be okay because i want a truck
you know yeah okay so no seriously this
is this is a problem you know i don't
know if i agreed to i don't know hold on
jared needs a new car
jared sees a used car i i
it's still the wrong question for 20 no
if i need a new car one cost me 26 000
and a new one cost me 22 000 and i have
a letter which that may be off not real
whatever
we will see
but to me it's math like the reason the
new car
principle it's math like so what
happened three years five years from
today what happens 30 years from today
to jared if he keeps asking questions
that he's trying to figure out a way to
make everything okay that he wants to do
i don't think this is this i know but
this rationalization process that people
use is what gets them in trouble so
here's a good idea it's just numbers
cars go down in value
don't buy expensive cars when you're
broke and 24 years old you know
don't do it you know but expensive car
though is by the number though i
understand but i there's a reason that
for 30 years i've taught people not to
buy new cars until they have a million
dollar net worth there's a reason and
the reason is and they're because they
go down in value like a rock so do the
used cars
and if you buy a 35 so my advice would
be completely different my advice would
be don't buy a car right now
it's a horrible time to buy a car oh no
it's a horrible time to buy a car answer
c so we didn't even go there
i've got the money to absorb the blow
and my net worth is considerably more
than a million dollars but if i was
getting ready to buy a car it wouldn't
be this year
i'm gonna drive what i got and let this
crap work its way out
okay but what if for people listening
though because i literally one of
it's a horrible time to build a house
yes right now yes because the materials
and the subs and the gcs are nuts
totally i know but if jared had to buy a
car though what would you say that if he
was homeless i'd tell him build a house
if he had to buy a car a time buy a car
and buy a new car you didn't answer it i
really wouldn't you would get the 26
thousand dollar used one i cuz number
one
i am just i'm not buying the premise
that it's all gonna work out okay
because i mean
i i was with a guy the other day
on the lot looking at a hundred and four
thousand dollars you weren't gonna buy a
new one i said i didn't say i was buying
it i was with a guy okay it's 104 000
car that you can't find yeah and they're
brand new and you can't find them
they're short on inventory like all cars
are you know what they're selling it for
140 000 brand new they marked it up 36
000 over msrp the dealer did on a brand
new vehicle that was sitting in the lot
right there yeah and i don't care if
it's a build order or not it's going to
land on the dadgum lot yeah and that
dealer and can only get so many of each
allocation of each vehicle and they can
mark them up 30 000 or they can sell you
one at what you built it on the web for
i ain't buying it i know but what is
that thing but what is it though when
you can build it online and buy it how
do they like i don't
listen i'm just telling you the pressure
is out there right now and until the
pressure subsides you're gonna have to
be careful yes you have to be careful
and and don't get in the habit of
trying to figure out a way
to do things
that that are perpendicular to what you
know to be true
yeah that's a bad habit
to put yourself in it's a bad question
to ask in that sense i'm not saying him
asking the question was invalid i
appreciate the discussion i like talking
about it arguing with you about it but
the uh i'm here god's sakes but
but the uh uh you know that that's the
thing i just you know it's a it's all
it's a whacked world right now and
horrible time to buy a car
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
number one new york times best-selling
author ramsey personality my daughter
rachel cruz is my co-host today on the
ramsey show in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage james
and ashley are with us hey guys how are
you
brick done good how are you better than
we deserve where do you all live las
vegas cool welcome to nashville good to
have you thank you so how much debt have
you guys paid off about a hundred and
sixteen thousand wow wow it's amazing
how long did that take about 15 months
good and your range of income during
that time it was about um 90 000 to a
180 000.
okay so uh what in the world
how do you double your income in 15
months well you marry a physical
therapist that works per diem at two
hospitals and she can pick up everything
during covent times so i'm working 80
hours basically
and and huge huge rate too because of
covid right exactly i rated it up yeah
wow wow that's incredible that's amazing
so now you can go back to a normal life
their income gonna come back down yes
but not not we're not um gonna bring it
down too much we're hoping to do about
um 120 per year okay that's pretty good
though that's pretty good well done
y'all what kind of debt is this was this
student loans in a car oh wow and then
some medical bills too okay how much of
it was student loans
a hundred and ten ish oh so most of it
yeah
pt
that's
my master's i kept under 30 000 the
whole time okay all right you get the
badge what do you do what do you do for
a living i'm an environmental health
specialist basically a health inspector
okay very cool good for you that's
awesome you guys so what happened 15
months ago that starts this journey
so um we got married september 2019 and
um when we got married
he was all about taking care of dad i
wasn't as much i was like i want to have
some fun
and um
he actually heard about your show
a little bit before we got married
basically i had been picking away
finding somebody that had good advice
because you don't tell this woman what
to do
don't even hint that she should do
something
you give her you have to tell her not to
do it and then she'll go do it that's
basically
wow so i started listening to your show
pretty regularly having it on while i'm
brushing my teeth and just around the
house from time to time and then she's
like hey who's that guy you're listening
to
so it was her idea oh yeah
i think he's a genius
it was my idea from then on
well she's also a bulldog so you get her
on a target and he you work you work 80
hours a week three different hospitals
yeah exactly exactly
that's amazing so you guys were newlywed
how long had you been married
you got married september september
2019. so how many months then i'm trying
to do the math so um we're married
we've been married four years yeah two
and a half years now
so basically a year in or so you start
um so we um after we got married we
started um around 2020
and then actually after that i injured
my knee because we were ready to do it
um beginning of 2020 i actually got
injured and then um after my injury
i just couldn't work so i got surgery
and it actually took a couple months and
so um around june 2020 that's when um
that's where kovett was really hell
broke loose all hell was breaking loose
and um i was cleared to work again and
as soon as i was cleared to work i was
like all right it's game on let's do it
wow and that's when the income jumped
obviously that's when i jumped yeah good
for you guys so as newlyweds
i feel like you know it's like we're
just so excited to be married you know
you guys have had you had established
careers even before you got married you
come together and you're like i just
want to live this awesome life
but you put everything on pause for 15
months to pay off debt so what was the
hardest part of that because i feel like
people get so excited and they just want
to just keep living life but you guys
really pulled back um for us it was
eating out and going on vacation
we're adventurers but of course covet
helped yeah we started the debt free no
that was wrong do anything exactly so
that really helped
and there's plenty of work for you to do
there was what were you but that is
that's at the height the apex
of uh not only uh caseload or cases of
covid but also it really wasn't the apex
of the cases it was but it was
definitely at the height of the
the fear yes fear was so thick in the
air in june of 20. yes that people were
mistreating each other they were mean to
each other uh if you went to work you
were evil if you didn't go to work you
were evil if you did whatever were you
scared to go to work at that time from
the standpoint of covid so at the
beginning um it was a little bit scary
because everybody was still trying to
figure out um how to
um
how to deal with kovid and how to better
protect herself especially in the
hospital or where um
yeah where kova is going to be and um
just learning like what type of
productive um equipment that you need um
but over time it just seems like it got
easier
good for you guys that's awesome do you
have any cheerleaders during this time
people that were for you and supporting
you um both of our parents were really
big cheerleaders for us they were
and they were like this is awesome like
they were with us the whole time and
then um i was talking to some of my
co-workers um some of the nurses they
thought it was really awesome too yeah
i've had a co-worker at work also bobby
donnell he's an awesome uh inspector too
but he's stuck in ish because his wife
isn't
as easily
sorry
not to teach him your technique to make
it her idea yeah
it's great very good way to go you guys
i'm very proud of you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
um honestly from for us we both have a
little different uh standpoint you got
to be a team is my view because
there's no way you're going to get
through it alone
and then for me is the motivation it's
just trying to find that motivation to
go to work um day after day like you
said 80 hours it's like you get pretty
run down so listening to your especially
pt because that's like real work exactly
and then by listening to your show um
before and after i go to work it really
helped
it's awesome you guys way to go you guys
so um actually i'm curious uh he said
teamwork and it's obvious you guys did
do this together and you were very in
sync but he also talked about how tough
it is to get you on board to do stuff
and you think you have your independent
thought yes um
and so forth which is good strong and uh
so
did you see
an unexpected
benefit
of you guys working together that you
didn't see coming we got really close
during this um with us being on
different pages
i think once we're on the same page we
it just got made our relationship a lot
closer and i feel like from here
we're able to discuss it a lot more a
lot better and um be on the same page
really we're a lot more effective at
making plans together and actually
seeing a goal and an insight so yeah the
weird byproduct is what i was observing
is in a brand new marriage where one of
you is super strong like that
learning to work this forced you to
learn to work together maybe where you
might have gone years
before you did that before you learned
that skill of working together yeah uh
and that that's what i thought i was
observing so way to go y'all thank you
so proud of you you're neat you're fun
people this is so fun well done so we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you number one bestseller and uh
that is definitely the next chapter in
your story you'll finish up your
emergency fund now and get that uh
retirement going and you'll be
millionaires before you know it and uh i
can tell that you're not afraid of hard
work you're not afraid of a challenge
you're not afraid of an adventure you're
gonna have some fun and you're gonna get
this done so very well done also a copy
of total money makeover you can give it
away to some friend that was a doubter
and maybe uh maybe that guy's wife yeah
we'll get it going right yeah you never
know
i got a gift for you i brought it from
nashville there you go
so good stuff all right james and ashley
las vegas nevada
116 000 paid off in 15 months making 90
to 180 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow amazing
very very powerful
you know rachel when you and
dr john deloney do the
money and marriage events
it is a
solid material that teaches couples uh
about their marriage and about their
money about working together on that and
we see in the actual data
how much the probability goes up of
someone not only getting out of debt but
becoming wealthy when they work together
oh absolutely because i mean it's like
you're putting two minds and even
mathematically two incomes everything is
is put together so it doubles in
efficiency and then the intimacy and the
fact that you're doing the impossible
together
gives you that much more fuel as well so
yeah you see it all the time and it's
awesome it's amazing and they're they're
proof of it yeah
that they are real proof i mean that was
neat those need watching that happen
right in front of us good stuff this is
the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money
a whole bunch of our social
media interactions these days are all
about taxes
[Music]
gag
just pisses me off when i say the word
taxes okay so oh it's awful but hey a
lot of you got questions about it well
no kidding you're special
job is the irs's job is to
make life ridiculously hard and they
have the island the misfit toys called
congress to help so we're here to help
make it a little easier
and a couple of things that keep coming
up one that has always come up and we've
always talked about this and really it
is one of the four or five things you
need to do as soon as you start
financial peace university as soon as
you start the baby steps
is to create a situation where you have
a zero
refund
nothing coming back nothing coming back
because a refund is not good yes because
the reason is number one
you are
taking money out of your paycheck that's
sitting in washington interest-free
where it could have been in your
paycheck using to pay off debt save it
for emergency fund all of it so the
thing you need to remember santa claus
does not live in washington yes but then
positive of that and there is that
feeling people get when you get a refund
in the mail it's like oh gosh it feels
like free money you did something yeah
well you did work it was your money yeah
you did do it because it's your money
but it's not a gift but it's not a gift
yes and it's not smart because you
basically have loaned your money to the
government interest free all year and
then you get your money back and like
woohoo like why are we celebrating this
i don't understand but that's so you
want a zero refund you don't want to owe
money above what you've had withheld
when you file your taxes and you don't
want to get a refund you want to zero it
out how can you do that
well a quick and dirty way to do it is
if nothing has changed in your situation
from the last year
and the tax law has not impacted changes
have not impacted your situation
then you say well last year i got a
three thousand dollar
tax refund the year before i got a three
thousand dollar tax refund well that's
250 a month
too much is coming out of your check and
so you can just march into payroll and
hr and say guys would you please adjust
my withholding by 250 a month
and if nothing has changed then you're
going to be right at zero
or there now it's never exactly that
simple so uh change it by not quite
enough so you get a tiny little refund
instead of having to write a tiny little
check but that's if nothing has changed
now if you bought a house you had a kid
yeah you
moved to states you run a business it's
not going to be that easy right okay the
the actual
technical way you can do this is
actually just do your taxes
for this next year under current tax law
but don't file them obviously you're not
going to file them in other words do
your taxes for 2022
pretend like you know what you're going
to make and do a tax return a fake tax
return that shows exactly how much tax
you owe
and have that much taken out of your
check in this year
and you will be two months yeah yeah so
you have predicted your actual tax bill
and had that actual amount taken out and
that should be zero yeah if you pre if
you predict it accurately what your tax
bill will be and so if you do your tax
is in advance you can zero it out every
time i have not done that i've done the
quick and dirty and rounded down and all
that in the past
to before i got before the tax returns
got so complicated at ramsey but but uh
but but you could if you want to be real
nerdy that's another way you can do it
the second thing that comes up is what
do we do if we have a side hustle
yes because that's everywhere now
whether it's yeah driving for uber or
yeah picking up i mean it's just it's
constant a lot of work from home it's
10.99 now yes so that's what i was going
to say
yes
yes we'll be at 10.99
yeah
so you know it basically you are
self-employed
for that portion of your income and
self-employed people
are required
to file quarterly estimates of taxes
and the way that's calculated is the
income you produced with your business
your side hustle your 10.99 your
freelance it's all a business
it's going to be filed on schedule c
which is a little tiny little form on
one page form on the back of your tax
return that you add for your
self-employed income
and it's basically your
gross revenues for your business what
you made minus any business expenses
that are deductible creates the actual
profit
of the business so that's three numbers
one minus two or two minus one equals
one you know three minus two equals one
whatever so your what you brought in
minus your profit or minus your expenses
equals your profit your profit times
your tax rate
is your is your uh tax bill your tax
bill on that money and you're supposed
to file that one little piece of paper
that shows income minus expenses equals
profit times tax rate with
a payment
for that tax bill
each quarter quarterly they're called
quarterly estimates and it is one page
there's not much to it yep but if you
get confused about that or zero in your
taxes out you can always go to an elp at
ramsey
uh
or you know and figure it out what
you're doing
and
they can help you do either one however
yeah we have now okay so i used uber as
an example and i should know this i
don't
if you're using if you if you work
though for a company
and it's not just yourself when does it
become freelance like when does it
become uber is all 10.99 that will be
10. you're not an employee when you work
for uber
you're not an employee you're not
signing an employee agreement now if you
work delivering pizzas you're an
employee yeah that's different but uber
is all 10.99 real estate agents i wonder
like airbnb when you make that's all ten
million income yeah
well that's not that's investment income
there that's managing rental property
with a rental income
so if you airbnb your house that's
considered oh if you're airbnb your
house i don't know what y'all that would
probably fall under small business
again you need to get tax advice the
last one that's driving everyone crazy
including us
is
the biden administration
has
completely lost their minds
and changed the tax the child tax credit
to the point that no human can
understand it
and um
we were we were considering attempting
to explain it
but it's just not explainable on the
radio
so here's the thing the tax credit for a
kid under 17 if you have children used
to be two thousand dollars
and now tax credit is different than a
tax deduction a tax credit comes off
your tax bill
so if you had a 3 000 tax bill and you
had to one child you'd reduce it by 2
000 and you only have 1 000 tax bill
that's how credit works it's an actual
dollar for dollar a deduction is not not
the same thing
now
here's the thing
the the credit
used to work before the american rescue
plan
which is a stupid name when did that
come in was that you're in covet though
that was 20 20. that was true
that was trump
the government's coming to rescue you
plan
oh help me lord
and so before before the only option was
to claim your tax credit when you filed
your income taxes
now
you file your tax cred and it all
changed in 2021
for and of course again yeah you're
going to file it this this spring yes to
get your tax credit and
uh
now it is 3 600 for kids is zero to five
uh three thousand dollars for kids six
to seventeen and five hundred dollars
for kids age 18 to 24 who claim who you
claim as a dependent because they're
enrolled in college so if you've got a
21 year old you can claim them now 500
worth
um
just because they are dependent on you
they're not filing in their own tax
returns for any reason in that case
which is would be dumb on a whole lot of
fronts uh but anyway they could do that
yeah
so
[Applause]
this is
unbelievably convoluted and complicated
and
um
i wish there was a way i could just be
brilliant and make it simple for you but
it's impossible because they've just
added another another volume to the tax
code to
uh try to confuse the crap out of you so
um
what i would tell you to do on this is
there's a blog at ramseysolutions.com
and if you want to nerd out and go into
the details
there's a full blog on the child tax
credit changes
and if you want to nerd out you can read
through it and it is actually you will
actually understand we wrote it in a way
where you can actually understand it um
but i just don't think it translates to
me reading it over the radio so i'm not
gonna do it so but the bottom line is
the tax child tax credits are larger
than they used to be they're broader
than they used to be the way you receive
them is even different the way you
receive them is different
it's worth checking into because you're
getting more money in most cases than
you used to get
[Music]
but you need to understand it and so do
the investigation don't just let this
happen to you
and then you'll figure out how awful it
is when the government comes to your
rescue this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author on the new york
times and many other lists is my co-host
today also my daughter as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
work your money
huh man it's all right there isn't it
you put those three together we about
got it so hey you jump in the phone
number's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five before we jump into your
calls though one of our good friends is
on the phone and uh we are honored to
have him back he's a regular on the show
pastor max liquido america's pastor how
are you max
i'm great dave it's always a treat to
hear your voice and and thanks for
giving me a few minutes today absolutely
rachel and i are honored to talk to you
always good to talk to you hi rachel how
are you great as rep before you got on i
said max located one of my favorite
people in the entire world so it's good
to be talking to you
you have to love max it's federal law
okay so um
new book from max liquido which is not a
shock he pretty much writes books like
he breathes so uh often and so uh this
is this is a fabulous 316
the numbers of hope over 1 million
copies sold
wow john 3 16 you know it is it's the
most famous verse in the bible
and if anybody knows anything about the
bible they know that verse if they don't
know anything about the bible i would
take them to that verse
for god so loved the world that he gave
his one and only son
that whoever believes in him shall not
perish but have everlasting life
you probably both of you all probably
have some memories around that verse
don't you oh oh the first verse i
memorized was it john 3 16. okay there
you go sunday school back in the early
90s yeah yeah football end zone is what
comes to mind for me but yeah isn't that
the truth no that's true the guys held
the sign up in every game since since
adam and eve
yeah
you know it it it does it surfaces for a
reason you know it it's it's kind of
like a table of contents to the
christian hope you know every word uh
matters
and and uh you know god loved world gave
one and only son you just go right down
through the verse
and every word uh you know it deserves a
deserves a book by itself at least a
chapter
and and that's that was my desire in
this book is to take that scripture word
by word and dedicate a chapter to each
of those words because it is so full of
hope in a time in which the world is in
such negative hope it is and i feel like
to max i mean i'm sure every generation
feels this way
but it's like our culture and our world
it feels more and more
anti-god almost the pushback against
just religion in general and then even
christianity so
it's interesting because it says so god
so loved the world right and so
tell me your thoughts on
you know
what you believe because of studying
scripture you know his perspective on
our world like a god loves a world that
doesn't love him that's what it feels
like yeah yeah
well you're spot on rachel it it there's
something going on these days uh
depression is on the rise
divorce filings are up 34
year to year
uh calls to listen to this calls to
mental health hotlines have increased
891 percent
and the suicide rate is the highest it's
been any time since world war ii
now i i know i know we want to chalk
that up to covet we want to chalk that
up to three years of
pandemic pandemonium and and there's a
lot of truth in that
but i think there's a deeper reason i i
think that
people simply don't know why we are on
this earth and they don't know where
we're going
uh we've got a lot of know-how a lot and
very little know why
and nothing tells us the why of life
more than john 3 16
it tells us that god loves us that he
gave his greatest gift for us that he's
done everything necessary
to bring us into
that dream that that that uh existence
we all dream of the eternal life
but he also the scripture is also honest
and that is he's not going to save
anybody who doesn't want to be saved
some people will perish
the other people will have eternal life
now i believe that when a person
understands where they're going in the
next life
that empowers life in this life
but if you don't know where you're going
in the next life
well odds are you'll become one of those
statistics those sad statistics of
anxiety and depression
and so this is a really important
message for this day and age
secularism has taken its toll on society
and we felt the body blow
of several decades now of being told
that there is no god or if there is a
god he doesn't care that's a bunch of
hogwash but it's taken its toll on
people
and so i i'm just praying that that the
lord will stir a revival in the hearts
to using good people like you guys and
maybe this book or something to light a
fire in which which people turn their
hearts back to him
well when it when it's just dark a
little bit of light shines pretty bright
so no doubt
certainly this book is one of those
lights and you're one of these lights
max liquido pastor max lucado our guest
this segment uh the new book is 316 the
numbers
of hope
over 1 million copies sold so the book
didn't just go on sale max correct
correct yes sir it actually released in
2007
dave oh
you know uh back in the uh i guess
pre-noah days that seems so long ago
but you know every so often the
publisher will say hey you know this we
got to re-release this we're going to
relaunch it so so we've done two or
three things uh i wrote some more
chapters to go in this new
revised version
uh we have created an online bible study
free online bible study at maxlekado.com
people can sign up today they don't have
to buy the book
they can study this verse with we got a
goal of 316 000 people going through
316. and also this is the first
full-length audio book i've ever
recorded really and so yeah i've i've
just never
done it i've always had voice issues so
i bailed out but oh my god i thought i'm
going to record this one myself
someone did a few extra things to
relaunch it yeah 316 the numbers of hope
on sale where
any good book is sold and uh i certainly
have my copy to go in my max locato
library now uh which i think is pretty
close to complete i have uh i've been
collecting them from you for a long time
um we've been been friends a long time a
great honor it is thanks to you it's a
great honor for me i remember the first
time i went i get to have lunch with max
liquido oh my gosh
145 million products in print translate
in 45 languages so if someone is
considered an expert in something i
think max
is considered an expert
let me just tell you that means you sold
over 100 million books a lot and there's
a very few authors even do a tenth of
that
the authors that are famous don't do a
tenth of that so max thank you brother
appreciate having you yes sir
pastor max lucado san antonio texas the
book is 316.
the numbers of hope
and don't you know we all need hope
right now more than ever this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
mental health your money your career
your work it's all here so how are your
resolutions going
if you're like most people you hit them
hard in january but by valentine's day
you're done
uh why because most time you're trying
to do it on your own with no plan
so if you decide to take control of your
money this year don't do it alone
get the support and accountability you
need
by joining a financial peace university
class
you're going to go through a proven
money plan with other people
who will help you stay motivated they'll
encourage you they'll hold you
accountable because they're trying to do
the same thing you are
and right now there are hundreds of
financial peace university classes
getting started both in person and
online
so no more lame resolutions make 2022
the year you actually get control of
your money and don't try to do it alone
find a financial peace university class
and get started right now with a free
trial
at ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu i was
uh flying home
where where where was i oh we were on a
trip to last week it was last week
on a southwest flight and i didn't check
in
that's a that's a rookie mistake when
you travel i didn't check in so i got
the c
boarding group so which means you get
the middle seat like you know someone
said i had to split up on the way here
um
so i was sitting in the middle talking
this guy next to me and you know he
asked me so what do you do and sometimes
i'm like in the mood to chat sometimes
i'm not i had a great book and i was
like i want to read my books i just said
i'm in finance so i just made it
broad he's like cool cool
which means don't talk to me well i was
like i don't know it sounds boring and
maybe there won't be a fall question
anyways but he started i don't know we
talked about something and i mentioned
personal finance that oh cool cool he
said well
uh my wife and i we finally got out of
credit card debt two years ago we're
debt-free paid off our house we just did
it i was like well good for you made you
do that because of course i kind of
perked up and he said well we did that
ramsay class
two years ago uh financial peace and we
went through it and we just did it and i
was like that's amazing i said
congratulations i know that takes a lot
of hard work all in code you never told
me
you never told him no because i want to
read my book
but i congratulated him but all that to
say all that to say no not a snob that's
gonna stop no i was flying under the
radar that's fine but i congrat but we
sat there and talked about how exciting
it was for him and i was excited for him
so you know we talked about it yeah but
all this to say fpu there it is if he'd
had any idea he was sitting next to
rachel cruz he would have gone bananas
i don't know
but but
in the curriculum like as part of the fp
lessons aren't you i am in it yeah i'm
in it but rachel traveling maybe look a
little different than rachel on video
with makeup
you don't do hair and makeup you don't
ever hear a makeup lady when you travel
yeah i know my glam squad decided not to
come james they didn't come this trip
but i like to say the fight fpu it's a
thing i mean it really does it i mean it
has helped obviously millions of people
but it is it's the thing you guys if
you're if you feel like you're kind of
like oh back and forth about stuff just
do it it's nine weeks he said just do it
yes i know so anyways that's good that's
a good story that's fun i like that
under the radar you are huh all right
incognito rachel see all that you
probably thought if it was rachel cruz
shirley shoot at least like say
something a
is not my
issue our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
so today's question comes from trevor in
idaho i'm looking for advice on
transitioning between baby steps two and
three
we will be debt free soon after a 27
month journey my wife wants to celebrate
with a vacation i get that
that would cost around 2 500 however i
want to continue asap on our emergency
fund should i get on board with delaying
the emergency fund for a small vacation
great question trevor so
you know you the the rule of thumb is
between baby steps one and three you're
all in because if you go on vacation and
you only have a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund and something happens
you're kind of screwed so
the idea i mean and maybe you just do
the emergency fund up to two months you
know
three months
three months yeah three to six months of
expenses yeah
here's before the vacation here's the
thing man you you are
yelling
you're yelling into the universe please
kick my butt
when you do this when you go on a
vacation and you don't have an emergency
fund you're asking
for something to break you're inviting
trouble into your home
and i mean it it's just the way it works
i mean the funniest thing is when you
get an emergency fund
you you virtually quit having
emergencies
it's the weirdest thing it's like it's
murphy repellent and so you don't want
to do this man i mean you're tr your
transmission is going to go out if you
do this
it's not you you don't want to do it
it's not worth it so it's not yeah you
know
i get it i whine
too i want to do the ending good good
and we all whine you know we all have a
whiner inside of us
and your wife is just whining a little
bit and i don't blame her i understand
yeah she all been busting it for 27
months so now you're going to have to
bust it for 32 months and then you're
going to go on vacation
that's what i would do i wouldn't go i i
would be scared
30 years of doing this i can just tell
you it's a weird
statistical thing i have observed that
you are asking for it and maybe and i
always think too trevor what are the
things that you guys can do to to
alleviate some of the like oh he's just
been
busting it so maybe it's like hey once
you because you have you you've paid off
debts maybe it's like once you hit that
one month emergency
into the into the three months like go
on a r go on like two great date nights
like right like like kind of scratch the
itch without having to just do it
you know
if you want to spend 300 on a dinner i'd
do that right maybe maybe i really
wouldn't do that but
but you're interesting i do that before
i go on vacation yes if you've got to do
something a little of the pressure off
if you've got to satisfy the whiner
inside of you and again i'm admitting i
have one too okay so it's not me yelling
at you but but if you kind of got to go
okay all right we're gonna do a little
dinner here and then we're gonna be back
game on and then we're never gonna have
to be this way again right beautiful
thing about finishing baby step three is
you should never have to deal with it
again unless you have a major emergency
and have to recoup your emergency fund
but by the time that actually happens
you're going to have money so you're
going to be all right but this is like
forever and ever i'm in we are done
don't go back in debt don't ever be
without an emergency fund it changes
everything it gives you the bandwidth
and everything so
i get it
but i think if we can just talk about
this out loud as a couple and go yeah
we're both tired and we're both whiny
and we both want to do it but really we
this is time to put your big girl pants
on big boy pants on and
suck it up buttercup you know i mean
finish it up well and there's that still
the momentum right so once you're debt
free
what was going out to payments like just
keeping that momentum of all that cash
just piling into that emergency fund but
it's hard baby step three
i talk to a lot of people and it's the
hardest it's one of those is so boring
well it's yes it's just boring paying
off death or some excitement it's like
gotcha your dad right you know but the
others just like get a little money get
a little more money it's just kind of
boring it's totally
it's anti-climactic after doing your
debt-free scream you know yeah and yeah
it's just i get it but dude it's
grown-up work it's just adult stuff we
have to do it
and yeah baby steps one through three
until you have that done you gotta be
game on rachel's right
so but yeah we're trying to say we
understand but that doesn't mean i would
do it
understanding uh feeling the pain with
you doesn't mean i would
you know put yourself in a baptism push
yourself put yourself make yourself
vulnerable like that because you're just
asking for your stupid tire to blow out
and then the second tire to blow out you
know i mean you got one spare but then
the other one and now you're on the side
of the road and and now vacation looks
like a dadgum movie scene or something
it's a
country song you know it's awful
and that's what ends up happening
so it's just interesting to me that when
i was broke i mean stone cold broke no
money which is kind of where you are
right now you're debt-free but you're
broke
is is when everything bad happens
but as soon as you start not being broke
it's like this the bad stuff goes next
door to the other neighbor
i mean it's like not all of it but a
bunch of it does
so it turns a crisis into an
inconvenience that's what you always say
about the emergency fund which is true
when you have the money it just kind of
becomes like a uh an eye roll versus it
takes out your whole world
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we
answer your questions about your life
your money your relationships your work
susan's with us in columbia south
carolina hi susan how are you
hey i'm fine babe thank you
um i have a question my husband is 54 i
am 52 we have a 20 year old son who is a
junior in college who is getting ready
to
apply to medical school and my question
is should we pay for medical school for
him
that presupposes that you can
yes how much money do you have
we have three and a half million in
retirement we make about 200 200 000 a
year and then we have about another 300
000 kind of
cash more liquid type sort of
um money okay you've done extremely well
congratulations you're very impressed
with you what do you all do for a living
we've worked hard at it yeah um we're
both engineers my husband is works
full-time and i work part-time
i just kind of stopped to stay home with
my son when he was little and i
worked enough to kind of stay current
number one category number one category
of employment of people who become
millionaires engineers and we don't make
a lot either so that's kind of amazing
together and you both worked hard for it
but that's a lot of money yeah yeah i
mean you're not making two million
dollars a year but you're doing really
good i'm proud of you very cool okay
is he your only son susan your only kid
he is okay so tell me your thought
process why are you asking this question
well
you know i i think that
kids should take some ownership in their
um
college and especially beyond you know
the basic four years has he so far but i
also
he has i mean he got scholarship he
works um i mean we have pretty much paid
but he definitely
contributes and and
takes care of himself basically we have
paid tuition and room and board
um and he got scholarship and it's in
state so it's really not been you know
it's been fine
um but my thought had always been that
beyond that you know that would be on
him
but i um i really the thought of him
coming out of school with you know a
quarter of a million dollars in debt is
not what i really want for him
and obviously he can't afford it you
know
he he works he saved up money but you
know he's got 15 000 in the bank he
doesn't he doesn't have enough to pay
for medical school so
i um you know it's kind of the whole
it's his education if he um
if he were to go to med school and you
were to pay for it
what would he what would you want him to
do
so that you felt like
that that was a wise decision and you
hadn't
uh the reason you're doing this is you
don't want to make it too easy the
reason you did it the statement earlier
i suppose is you didn't make it too easy
on him you want him to have some
backbone you want him to have some
structure to his character right
yeah and so what would he have to do
what would he have to do in your mind
for to be okay
for you to pay for med school and you
still were comfortable because all i
hear so far is a stellar young man
he is
he is i mean i um he would have to
graduate i guess and you know not
misbehave
yeah yes
most people don't work when they're in
med school but would you want him to
work or
i really wouldn't necessarily you know i
um he's had to he's worked since he was
15 during the summer he didn't work
during the school year up until this
year he just got a job at school on his
own
um so
i kind of think school is priority you
know except for when you're not in
school so i don't
i don't necessarily i i just
i just didn't know you're hardworking
people and you don't want to raise a kid
that's not
yes it's a big gift yeah it's a big you
know not a kid it's a it's a big gift
it's a big two would be a sacrifice two
lenses susan i would say for you guys
because the conversation this is even
happening because you guys can pay for
it you can pay cash you're not going
into debt for it so
you know with money we always say that
money makes you more of what you are so
in a sense if you put a magnifying glass
on him and his character and his heart
and who he is
and that this is kind of a reflection
this is going to expand him right
because it's a that's a very generous
gift that you're giving him what's going
to be expanded who is he and he sounds
like he's an amazing kid right he's a
junior in high school or a junior in
college who's awesome so that's what's
magnified and when parents are like i
don't want to spoil my kids
and spoil means go bad right it's if you
had spoiled food it smells it's gross
but i don't feel like that this is
what's gonna cause his character right
so i think parents hesitate to give
their child a gift thinking that it's
gonna ruin who they are but their
character's been built up to this point
and if you don't believe like this isn't
gonna ruin him and his work ethic and
who he is
it's a it's a blessing to be able to do
that in my opinion awesome i mean i want
to
but i just didn't want to do
you don't enable anything yeah well i
mean
when rachel and her brother and sister
went to school
uh we paid for their they're both all
four graduated from undergrad we paid
for all of it and um the rule was was
that we knew the person going in to that
already had a work ethic
we knew the person going into that
already was going to live on a budget
because they've been doing it when they
were at home and they're gonna do it
there it's part of the deal and uh you
know we're people of faith so you're
gonna be walking with god you're not
gonna be down there playing beer pong
all weekend
and laying in a ditch drunk somewhere
you know it's not gonna you're not gonna
stay on the payroll if you do that i
mean these are the discussions we had
and um so you know
and so what we ended up with was we had
great young
adults who performed fabulously all
three of them but none of us are smart
enough to go to medical school well but
they know they went through
that's okay that's not the point the
point is is that we paid for it and it
didn't ruin them because they were
already built
and they you know
they finished all the way through and
and now they're out of school obviously
all all three of them and they're all
married now and all
their lives have continued successfully
but it and and so it's not the actual
paying for school that ruins someone
it's not it's it's having not built
character into them and not requiring
boundaries on the gift and so my gift to
him if i were involved in this
discussion on as parents would be uh
this is a gift but it's not an
unconditional gift it's contingent upon
you continuing to be the stellar young
man that you are and that you're not
only going to go to class you're going
to do the work to get out of this we're
going to be involved in the picking of
which med school because we're not going
to go to the super expensive one because
nobody asked where your doctor went to
school and so we're going gonna you know
we're gonna pay reasonable prices uh and
you're gonna be we're gonna be involved
in all that still since it's our money
not be controlling but we have a say in
it and you you know the the
the faucet gets cut off if you're going
to misbehave it's not no matter what you
do or how badly you behave we have to
give you money because we don't
and so if you keep doing exactly what
you've been doing we are going to be
honored to support you through med
school that would be how it would sound
like coming from our house and that's
how it sounded like when you all went
off to school
yeah absolutely mm-hmm
that helps you i
yes it helps so much it really does i
love that money makes you more of who
you are i mean that
that i wrote it down that resonates
and um he i mean he wants to go into
state because he knows in state tuition
there's the same thing for medical
school as there is for you know
other school and state tuition is almost
half for medical school so he is looking
out for that as well it's awesome i like
this kid what a great kid this is great
you did good mom
you did great yeah thank you thank you
and thank you all for your um
your wife's words i really appreciate it
thank you we're honored to talk to you
and uh see that's the thing that
that's an everyday millionaire that's a
baby steps a millionaire someone who
s your their engineers they use systems
and processes they fit in their 50s they
got three million dollars it gives them
options to do something like this and
then you can have those kinds of
discussions yeah it's awesome
it's the result of it right all the hard
work and all the even our
trevor from blinds.com and a few
segments ago of like my emergency you
know it's like if you just stick to the
plan you do it
over a long period of time these you get
to do whatever you want you get to send
your kid to medical school and pay for
it i mean that's pretty awesome one of
the things i put in this last book baby
steps millionaires was a chapter on
if i become a millionaire does it ruin
my kids
and you know we address that in smart
money smart kids as well yep and the
answer is no it doesn't ruin your kids
you already ruined your kids before you
got money or you already didn't ruin
your kids before you got money that
that's the deal that had nothing to do
with the money this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
eric is in bloomington illinois indiana
rather hey eric how are you i'm doing
quite possibly better than i deserve i
don't know
i understand how can we help
well um
we took an offer on our house um
we chose not to pass up
and
we'll be closing
end of may
and should be
walking away from the closing table with
about 370 thousand dollars fun which is
yeah
um
and
we're committed to staying here in
bloomington
until my youngest graduates high school
which should be
may of 23.
and um so for another year
and we're debating whether to buy or to
rent
and if rent what to do with the cash
the way i answer questions on this show
is if
where are you moving after you leave
oh um
well
when we tell the house now we're going
to stay here no i know but i mean when
you leave town where what town are you
going
um
we're going to move closer to our
our family
which might put us in oklahoma okay okay
cool
all right
um
the way i answered questions i was what
i was getting ready to say on the show
and the way rachel does is what will we
do if we woke up in your shoes and we're
in this situation
i would rent
okay because buying might
uh
mess up your goal of leaving
right let's just pretend that interest
rates went up which there seems to be
some pressure that direction
and that the housing market not only
slowed down it came to a screeching
freaking halt
about the time your daughter graduates
now if you are renting you can take your
375 000 in a down market like that and
make a really great buy
in oklahoma if you own
you got to sell a house in a screwed up
market
and i'm not suggesting that the housing
market is going to swing that far in 12
months i doubt it will in 12 months
it's only done that once
in history and that was in 2008 that it
swung that far in 12 months but
i do think that the this white hot
market that you just took advantage of
is going to be unrealistic
to continue indefinitely
and so it's the supply demand curve is
what's causing it it's going to catch up
i mean the building supplies are going
to catch up so um
and then the prices are going to
stabilize the market's going to calm
down and it's going to be less of a
seller's market i and i think it's going
to be more that direction than it is now
12 months from today but you could
probably sell the house but i just don't
want you get stuck with one your goal is
to leave
right right so i would
but you're not going to lose anything
okay it's just sitting there it's just a
parking place for your money it's a
parking lot
storage you been for your money you know
until next year and then you're gonna go
buy a house with it and take your time
and you might actually end up renting
for six months in oklahoma until you
find the right deal so you don't get
pressured into buying something stupid
on the move right
right okay the trick in this kind of a
market is to sell high
and buy low
not sell high and buy high
right
that's you know
and that requires some you know some
patience and setting yourself up to not
get caught in in in a crossfire on
something okay so a little bit of a turn
here but i think it's in the same vein i
just feel like
i don't know maybe it's the news i watch
and what i'm reading online all of it
but everything from interest rates
housing markets
inflation like i just like there's so
much heightened
almost anxiety just around money and the
uncertainty and even like russia and
ukraine like the whole thing right like
people are like nervous about that and
that inflation's gonna skyrocket if
russia like
there's just a lot of
um
anxiety i feel like there's a lot of
negative news about the economy and
about the state of affairs when it comes
to finance yeah and and so yeah there
should be so how do you incur like
what's your there should be some anxiety
around that because you see inflation
continuing to rise and like all that
like well i don't i don't see inflation
continuing to rise like it has been
because this is a different kind of
inflation than the jimmy carter era yeah
on the 70s and the early 80s but even if
russia anything with like i don't know
any other global i don't think that's
going to change our lives you know 20
years from today yeah but um be shocked
if it does but the uh but all the
uncertainty that's in the air
and the pressures on the market
are all it's kind of a perfect storm
there's a whole bunch of bad stuff
happening right at this moment
and it's all kind of camouflaged or
covered over by the fact that people are
making more money yes because there's
this shoot up in incomes
and and there's a shoot up in personal
debt credit card debt the highest credit
card debt on uh since like 2007
this year in 2021 it's out of control
spending people are spending their
brains out out there and so what these
kinds of economic indicators end up
doing is we end up having some kind of
problem with their overall the economy
that does affect your life unless you're
the third pig
and so the way you handle the anxiety of
the negative news about
that
you know not not taking any of it to the
extreme where you think that all the
world's coming to an end because it's
not
not on any of these issues but uh but
but you do know okay i'm concerned i'm
not freaked out i'm concerned well
concern's good because that makes you
get ready for the storm i'm afraid
there's a storm coming yeah i don't
really think i'm gonna hit both a
tornado but i'm gonna prepare and act
like you know we're gonna act like we're
gonna act like you know that we're gonna
have some good sense we're not gonna
stand out in the yard and look for it
right and so uh the third pig means
that's the third pig and the three
little pigs that built a brick house and
that means you get out of debt you have
an emergency fund you have a budget you
start to build some wealth and when you
don't have any debt you have a pile of
money and bad things happen in the
economy it doesn't affect you yep nearly
as bad as if you have no money and
you're deeply in debt
it destabilizes everything so i i i
never want to call have fear be the
motivator i want hope to be the
motivator but if you are feeling anxious
and a lot of people are
about some of the economic indicators
let that be your motivation to get your
crap together
oh my gosh this is your call hello you
know i mean that's really what it is
yeah well and giving and that gives
people a sense
that you can control what you can
control right like what's going on in
your house those are variables you can
control yes it's focusing on that and
all this other stuff that you just can't
you can't if you think the republicans
are going to save your life you're wrong
and if you think the democrats are going
to save your life you're really wrong i
mean it's just not going to happen
you know
i've been doing this i'm old and i've
never gotten anything out of washington
except trouble yeah you know i mean it's
just trouble they don't bring anything
good to me so and that's not just being
anti-government or something it's just
it's called personal responsibility i'm
an adult and i'm responsible for my
future joe biden thank god is not
responsible for my future or a
republican president trump thank god
it's not responsible for my future if i
thought either one of them were in
charge of my future i would just be
going i would really have anxiety then
but thank god i know they're not so i
can control the controllables in my life
i can keep my job i can use that money
to build my 401k i can get out of debt
have the emergency fund stay out of debt
i do not have to participate in panic
purchases
oh god it's going up i gotta buy six of
them oh geez man come on
just extra cases of water just in case
y2k some of y'all are still sitting on
that eight gallons of peanut butter from
y2k
and some of you don't even know what
that is because you weren't born yet
oh my gosh but anyway not in the booth
the people in the booth all do know but
hey you got to be 22 years old or older
are you doing that you are not born
that's weird that's beautiful that's
weird yeah
i'm usually feeling young i'm like the
youthful one here on this show
everything so everything's a matter of
comparison all these terms i'm usually
like i'm the one that's kind of out but
i actually now feel old yeah but y2k is
yeah how old were you in in 2000 in 2000
i was 12. yeah okay when the world
almost came to an end and y'all had a
new year's eve party that year we had a
great one
they served water
what no everybody was stockpiling water
because you were going to be able to get
water and you didn't drink bourbon back
the grid was going to be a the grid was
going to be off the line we were going
to lose everything or you know all your
bank accounts are going to be frozen hey
you did probably hold your breath for a
little bit when it was like three two
one
what's gonna happen and then everything
all the lights stayed on and we went
right here we are america 22 years later
yeah cheers this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice this is a
baby steps millionaires theme hour a
theme hour about everyday millionaires
about people who have become
millionaires however it happened i don't
care how you became a millionaire i want
to talk to you this hour
if you want it in the lottery if your
mama left you the money if your rich
uncle left you the money if you've
worked hard for 832 years and saved your
money
whatever it is i want to know how you
did it because people out there need to
know the real story not the crap they
hear on the news by some political
talking head with an agenda
and by the way statistically the stuff
they say on the news about millionaires
is crap
so let me help you what a millionaire is
and then if you are a millionaire you
can call and i want to talk to you today
during this hour a millionaire is owned
there's only one definition for it that
is the correct definition that's not
just dave ramsey this is just
how things work this is the reality okay
a millionaire is not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
a millionaire is someone with a one
million dollar or greater
net worth
now your net worth is defined as what
you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities now sometimes people
want to get chinchy about what they want
to count in their assets you can count
whatever you want to count your assets
if you can sell it and turn it into
money it's an asset
you have to sell it fast but if it could
be sold and turned into money it's an
asset
and so if you have a collection of farm
equipment that is an asset not
necessarily going to sell it might keep
it if you've got a collection of
whatever it's an asset if you've got a
collection of money it's an asset
minus what you owe is 1 million or
greater than you are a millionaire by
definition well
million dollars nobody should have a
million dollars it shouldn't be done
this is not a moral discussion
it can be but millionaire is not a moral
construct it's a math idea
a million dollar net worth well million
dollars isn't enough it might not be but
that's not it still doesn't define what
a million dollar net worth is and it's
not a million dollars cash and it's not
a million dollars only in investments
your house counts in this
you know you're what you own
minus what you owe
is your net worth
so if you have a great of a net worth of
million dollars or greater i want to
talk to you this hour because i want to
find out how you did it so that other
people can learn from you and then they
can go do it pretty simple idea this
isn't i this i do this baby steps
millionaires our everyday millionaires
hour is all about hope
that's what it's about the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five jake is in saratoga new york
jake what is your net worth
uh 1 million and 23 000. you're right
there huh i love it okay how old are you
35 oh you're a young millionaire good
job well done jake all right and give me
the mix on that the breakdown what's it
how's that million dollars made up
so we have uh 600 and 401ks
25 in roth
35 and taxable
22 and 529 accounts
uh 8 000 in hsa
33 in cash and 300 in home equity all
right all right i like it very good
very good how much of this did you
inherit
zero zero cool and what has been your
working
your best year household income and
worst your household income during your
working life
our best year combined was last year at
uh about 260. cool and our our first
year together we did about 80 when my
wife was in school gotcha okay what do
you do for a living
i'm a mechanical engineer i do a
construction oversight for a utility
company
your degree in engineering physician
assistant are you watching mechanical
engineering okay yeah and so you're
engineered by trade and your gpa in
college was what
i i wasn't an a student i was uh i was
like a b c student
so like a 3.0 2.5 what
yeah 2.5 2.75 maybe gotcha okay cool
very cool now you did this really young
you know that right yeah now you got so
so you do you feel like you got some
kind of a head start what what was the
what how what enabled you to do this by
35 and get your first million dollars
the biggest thing was i just started
investing in the 401k you know right out
of school
and
you know knowing what i know now i would
have hit that a lot harder
yeah because it worked
that in your real estate in your house i
mean these are the two things that got
you there basically yeah
yeah so are you guys um
you and your wife you you're both
professionals you both work really hard
i'm sure
um you're making really good money but
you put in hours to do that without a
doubt um
are you guys
in sync on what you do with money how
unified are you
yeah you know we have a plan we do the
every dollar budget we talk about it
every month
we decide where the money is going to go
before we get it
there you go okay do you guys use an
investment professional we don't take on
debt okay no debt do you use a pr uh a
an investment professional to help you
no i never have okay um i've just done
it solo you just went and looked at the
mutual funds and figured out which ones
you wanted
yep and it worked good for you okay very
good man i'm proud of you i'm proud of
you so do you think that uh anybody can
do this today in america
yeah absolutely
okay what would you tell them the secret
is
just don't take on any debt just save as
much as you can load up the 401k i wish
i was putting money into ross when i was
younger
that would have made a big difference
for me now
just don't take on the debt i mean we
had debt we had 120 000 in school debt
you know long before we knew about you
and we just got after it and paid it off
and that allowed us to build wealth
yeah
you must have been rid of that for a
while though yeah very good
well way to go jake proud of you man
very well done see that's what a
millionaire sounds like y'all
it's not what your broke brother-in-law
describes at thanksgiving
this is not he does not know what a real
millionaire is
jake's a real millionaire that's what
they all sound like they all sound just
like him
i mean it's very it's like a it's like a
club or something and you have to sound
like that to get in the club i don't
know what it is i mean but we're going
to talk about this hour and you're going
to hear a lot of the same things over
and over and over again because it turns
out the principles that cause you to
build wealth uh haven't changed
are still available to you
and yes you can do this in america today
and
some people have a different starting
line than others
there's no question about that some
people have it harder than others to get
there hey i'm so stupid i had to do it
twice
okay i was a millionaire by the time i
was 26
but i had borrowed up to my eyeballs in
debt lost everything
went bankrupt
because i was stupid
the mess i had gotten myself into
and my young family
and had the opportunity to start over
with nothing at 28 years old
so i started over with nothing well you
you know you got you got rich by filing
bankruptcy
honey there bankruptcy is never a method
of building wealth
that's a dumb but statement when people
say that
bankruptcy never causes people to build
wealth be wealthy that's just dumb
so we're gonna talk to real millionaires
baby steps millionaires theme hour the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five on the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a millionaire theme hour if you're
a millionaire you have a net worth of a
million dollars or greater i want to
talk to you this hour and find out how
you did it so that other people can do
what you did those of you listening if
you'll do what they did and not what you
hear from broke people
then you will go and be millionaires
and you will find these formulas to be
proven
and time-worthy and wise the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five scott is with us in
virginia beach hey scott how are you
dave i'm doing fine hope you're doing
the same i am sure what's your net worth
uh right just north of 3.5 million good
for you okay give me a little breakdown
on that by category
okay i've got it broken down into three
categories uh the first one are
retirement counts which are about two
million dollars and we've got that uh
between you know some self-directed iras
our current 401ks and then a couple of
roth iras perfect and then we've also
got about a million just invested in
non-retirement accounts you know just
multiple mutual funds in our emergency
fund
and then the last
which is our house which is valid at
about 550 000
and then i'm proud to say that
last august uh fully paid for so no
mortgage payments so we are entirely
debt free so uh i guess you're talking
one of those weird people now i love it
congratulations brother how old are you
59 59 good and how much of this money
did you inherit
uh about maybe 20 000 i had a family
member that passed away about a year ago
but uh that is the only thing that was
actually i guess given to us so you were
already millionaires
many times over before you got this yeah
that's correct okay cool correct good
all right and so your best year
household income working
uh and your worst year
let's see uh
the best year about 120 000
and that was about last year and then uh
my worst year i guess my first year out
of college and that was back in the mid
80s was 18 000 and really at that time i
thought 18 dollars i had the world i
thought that was really yeah that was a
lot of money i i made 18 000 when i came
out of college that's a lot of money
yeah so uh what was your what's your
career
i'm in sales in the transportation
industry okay good for you what was your
degree in college uh in business okay
good for you and what was your gpa
i have to laugh because i knew i've been
listening to the millionaire theme there
for a while and i knew you're gonna ask
that question
so i want to give it to you in two parts
if i can sure uh there's there's the
first two years and then the last two
years
[Laughter]
well there's a story behind this the
first two years when i was in college i
was only 17 years old
and i was just a stupid immature kid
so um i can truly say that i was the
fraternity and campus champion in
beeruppong yeah and my grades reflected
that so my grade my first two years was
just enough to stay out of academic
probation got it okay so then um yeah so
then i came home after my sophomore year
and then this is long before email my
dad got a hold of my grades and then uh
all i can say is when he saw those
grades we had a little uh come to jesus
meeting and um
i will never ever forget that
conversation it was 39 years ago and
basically he lit into me like a
firecracker so uh
i got myself turned around probably well
the word conversation may be a little
different because it takes two people to
have a conversation and all i remember
it was my dad that did all the talking
as a result of that my last two years i
went back to school i started my junior
year grief focused uh just had a whole
new strategy and then my last two years
my gpa was about a 3.2 so i think when
you average out the first two years and
the last two i think i finished up about
a 2.5 or 2.6 okay i love it that's great
well done all right how much uh of this
net worth this wealth that you have
built you feel like you've got because
you used debt to build wealth
i never the only thing i have borrowed
money for was to buy the house okay so
there's none basically no no that's
right cool
so uh if um
your 25 year old version of you that's
in business school just gotten out of
business school and is starting their
sales careers out there listening right
now what would you tell them is this
possible and if it is what should they
do
well let me tell you i've got a daughter
who is just getting out of college
and i have actually shared her story
my story with her on how we got to where
we are
and my
first of all you can do it and my advice
is to invest and start early
since day one when i got my first job
you know i've always invested you know
in the 401k with every paycheck
and as i tell my kids as they enter the
job market you know when money is
deducted before you get send your
paycheck it goes directly into your
retirement account you never see it and
you never miss it so how can you miss
something that you never had so my
advice is to start early
um and just
it's it's a marathon it's it's not a
race it's not a get rich fast scheme
it's a marathon and you can win
and it can be done with anybody of any
uh with any type of revenue okay you and
your wife spend more time in books or in
tv
uh
right now we're empty nesters so we
spend a lot of time in front of tv okay
fair enough
fair enough but um yeah i mean as far as
doing books i'm not a really avid reader
i never have been but i'll read about
maybe two to four a year
mostly you know business self-help and
self-motivation mm-hmm
best best show that you guys have
watched lately
what's what's when you're you're just
stuck on we are what is what you know uh
the morning show on apple tv this is
pretty good oh okay all right good
fun well man you're incredible
congratulations you got to feel
accomplished because you are
well we're on a few years from
retirement i think we have uh basically
paved that path so when retirement comes
in about three years uh i think we set
ourselves up pretty for pretty good
success yeah i mean basically it'll
double again in seven years so when
you're 66 you're gonna have seven to
eight million dollars
uh looking forward to it that's where
you're heading that's pretty strong
place and so
you know we're looking at a ten million
dollar plus net worth uh when we get to
your estate plan so well well done very
very well done man that's amazing
impressive impressive thank you thanks
for talking to me open phones at
825-5225 if you're a millionaire i want
to talk to you jennifer is in new york
city jennifer what's your net worth
hi dave my net worth's about 1.4 million
good for you give me a little breakdown
on that by category please
so about
375 is our paid for house we have about
62 000 in savings accounts
about 67 000 in 529 accounts
uh 20 000 in a ross ira
about 20 000 and paid for cars and the
rest is in my 401k so you got close to a
million in that 401k
yes okay good for you all right well
done how old are you
i am 48 and my husband is 52. excellent
cool how much of this 1.4 million did
you guys inherit
um i inherited 10 000 back in like 2003
but i was stupid back then and i spent
most of it and then i inherited another
10 000 in 2018
and at the time we were just starting
baby step six so that ten thousand was
my very first baby step six payment on
the house very cool but it's it's fair
to say mathematically you're not
millionaires because of inheritance
absolutely not right okay so what's your
best year working income household
income and what best and worst year
so this year we're set for our best year
at about 225
when we first got married we were making
about a hundred thousand that was about
18 years ago cool what do you do what's
what's your career
i'm a software engineer okay
all right
your degree is in what
computer science okay cool what was your
gpa
it's about a 3.85 good for you good very
cool all right so again same question
but i think it's bears repeating because
everybody's got their own take on it um
can if if you've got a 24 year old
version of you that's listening and they
are by the way
um can this still be done in america
and
what would they need to do to do it
yes this absolutely can be done um just
four short years ago our net worth was
maybe
200 000
and we followed the baby steps and and
we're now millionaires four years later
absolutely 100 baby steps millionaires
and i would tell anybody in their 20s
do not chase the new car smell because
that will keep you broke your whole life
and if i had not bought so many brand
new cars
in my life i think our net worth would
be well over three million by now oh
well two anyway yeah
yeah
very good i love it well thank you for
sharing jennifer you guys are heroes i'm
proud of you
very very well done another baby steps
millionaire
people like that inspired me to write
this last number one best-selling book
that we have called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
well over the last 30 years i've walked
with millions of people and their
families to help them overcome financial
stress we've seen all kinds of stress
out there and right now people are
struggling with stress anxiety
loneliness all kinds of issues
it's kind of
gone crazy out there
and you know what here's the good news
dr john deloney ramsey personality has a
new book
called own your past change your future
where he'll walk you through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness
through his personal stories decades of
experience and research dr delunie shows
us how to transform hurt
into healing and move from hopelessness
to hopefulness
and dr loney's book is available right
now for pre-order own your past change
your future we'll help you deal with
different kinds of trauma to get
connected to a community
talk about how to make friends as an
adult
and all the steps you can take to change
your thoughts your actions
yes it's possible this book is
incredible your mental health matters
and here's why you should pre-order it
you're going to get free bonus items
including a month of free one-on-one
weekly therapy so pre-order your own
copy of own your past change your future
for only twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com
today
it's a millionaire theme hour and every
day millionaire theme hour a baby steps
millionaire theme hour we're talking to
millionaires regardless of how they got
there when they got there we want to
know how people become wealthy in
america today
not someone's theory i want to talk to
people who really did it
see when i went broke when i was 28
years old lost everything after i was a
millionaire i decided i wanted to learn
how money really works so what did i do
i studied best practices we call it in
business
i went and started interviewing old
millionaires old rich people any old
rich person i could run into i would ask
them how they did it where did their
money come from how did you do it how
did you do it
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him he was stupid
i didn't want his opinion
and if you're young and rich i'm fine
with that it doesn't bother me but that
didn't what i did i talked to old rich
people and they taught me this thing
called common sense that i didn't have
any of i had plenty of academic prowess
and i can i could spout you all the
theories that broke people often spout
about money but none of them had led me
to wealth as a matter of fact they led
me to misery
and so i decided i was going to learn
how money really works i talk to old
rich people so that's what we're doing
we're talking to rich people some of
them old some of them young
some of them from any all of them had
different starting points some of them
it was easy to do some of them was hard
to do
you know
but how did you do it and once you hear
enough of that then you're going to know
two things one is it can be done meaning
you can build wealth in america today
and two
you're going to start hearing common
themes that if you want to be wealthy
these are the themes in your life this
is how you want to live your life
tim is in austin texas he's a
millionaire tim what's your net worth
2.2 dave good for you man well done so
give me a little breakdown on that
what's the categories
all right so 401k is about 1.4 between
me and my wife
we have about 40k and just savings
that's emergency fund you know very
liquid
we have about 135k and just various
mutual funds about 50k and iras i've got
about 6k in company stock and some
unvested stock i don't
count toward my
net worth
and then the house
which is paid for praise god and that
one i i waffle on because the tax
appraised value is 460 but the market
here in austin is crazy so it's probably
actually more like 700. yeah but that's
that's the breakdown yeah it's not tax
value doesn't matter all that matters
what you sell it for and you probably
saw it that's absolutely right yeah good
for you well done boom
fun how old are you
i'm 56. good for you okay cool and how
much of this 2.2 million did you inherit
well
the only thing we've inherited is my
in-laws when they passed they left us a
house and about 100k so
when we got the house it was at the
bottom of the housing collapse in 2007
so
didn't make a whole lot out of that it
was about 200 000 but that was 10 years
ago we were already on the path it
wasn't the thing that pushed us over the
top if you if you know what i mean okay
but you did inherit 300k
200k 200 200 plus the house right
well the house and the house is 100 100k
on top of that so it's 200k total yeah
oh i see okay cool good for you well
done all right and the range of income
during your working life best years and
worst years
all right 27k when i got out of college
eons ago and 180k as a couple
last year okay what do y'all do for a
living
well i'm i'm a security and i.t manager
for security so you can imagine with all
the russian ukraine stuff we're going
nuts at the moment
my wife my wife was a stay-at-home mom
for
most of
that period of time in our marriage but
she's just recently in the past several
years started up an amazon fba business
oh wow good okay so is your degree in
computer science
it's computer engineering yep computer
engineering okay what was your gpa
365
good for you okay cool
all right again the question you often
hear me ask i'm sure is
the 24 year old version of you that's
listening
can they still do this and if they can
what should they do
all right so
uh my first thing that i would always
communicate to anybody at that level is
you can't out give god
you have got to make uh you need to make
giving a priority in your life and what
i've lived by
my life is malachi 3 10 11. it's not a
guarantee of wealth god doesn't promise
us if you give them ten percent he's
gonna give us a lottery ticket you know
that
but
he does have a way in malachi 311 of
rebuking the devour
and that doesn't mean you know you talk
about murphy living in your back bedroom
well with god murphy's got a padlock on
the door and he only lets him out every
once in a while to give you a few trials
and and
to help you persevere so it's it's kind
of a
scenario for me that giving has got to
be a priority and that's something that
my wife and i have have made
the second thing for me is i wish for my
25 year old self one of the things i did
right
was
getting into my 401k very first
month i was on the job that i was vested
to do so
my problem is i only put in the amount
that up to what they would match and i
wish now
i had i had heard dave ramsey back then
and put 15 percent because now i would
be retired instead of
of just putting in six percent which is
what i put in at the time
so that's
that's what my advice would be
get the max you can put in and that you
can afford to put in and ramp yourself
up uh to 15 at least
the last thing for me is
don't use credits to credit cards to buy
stuff you can't afford that was my train
wreck between my 20s up to age 30 before
i got married is use the credit card and
i you know i would sit there and say oh
that's only a thousand dollars well it's
a thousand dollars with minimum payments
it'll take me 10 years to pay off and
i'll pay 10 grand for it that was the
foolishness of of that thinking i was as
as you said i was normal and i shouldn't
have been normal
well done sir well said and well handled
congratulations i'm very very very proud
of you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we talked to
real millionaires
uh
the lies that are out there
millionaires all inherited their wealth
it's a lie
statistically actual data
actual research known as facts
tells you that that's a lie
here's what we know we did the largest
study of millionaires ever done airtight
research in north america
here at ramsey research
studied over 10
000
millionaires
and they weren't all ramsey listeners it
was airtight the process the the
research methodology was studied by an
outside firm to ensure that it was
accurate
79 of the millionaires in america did
not inherit a dime
five percent inherited a small amount
like a five thousand dollar or ten
thousand dollars which obviously does
not make you a millionaire and another
five percent inherited some money that
was substantial after they were already
millionaires
89 of america's millionaires are not
millionaires because of inherited money
that is a lie
it's a lie
you can do this you don't have to depend
on a rich uncle because you don't have
one
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
psalms 104 24
how many are your works lord in wisdom
you made them all the earth is full of
your creatures
albert einstein said creativity is
intelligence having fun i love it that's
great this is a millionaire theme hour a
baby steps millionaire theme hour
because a lot of the folks calling in
have followed the baby steps and become
millionaires but lots of people call in
regardless of how they became a
millionaire we only talk to millionaires
during a millionaire theme hour because
we want to
let you guys out there know that aren't
yet millionaires how these other folks
did it so you can do what they did it's
a pretty simple formula
and it also defeats all the mythology
out there
all wealthy people are crooks
nope
i hadn't talked to a crook today yet
and these are all wealthy people i'm
talking to
none of them stole the money
they're not crooks
as a matter of fact the percentage of
crooks among wealthy people is about the
same as the percentage of crooks among
poor people it turns out that just a
percentage of the population are crooks
it has nothing to do with the money the
money just happens to show up bigger and
splashier when the crook is rich or gets
rich being a crook
but it's not a proven method to build
wealth to be a crook quite the opposite
as a matter of fact well all wealthy
people are famous entertainers or
athletes you have to be in the nba or
you have to be
a country music star or a rock star or a
music star and
no
less than one percent of wealthy people
people with a million dollar net worth
or greater
in north america fall into those
categories
most of these people you walk past them
at walmart and didn't even know you're
next to them
because they don't dress that much
different than you they just act
different than you
they save instead of spend
they give instead of take
it's a different thing it's all it is
well you got to be brilliant to be a
millionaire you have to have a 4.2 gpa
and i just don't have that kind of brain
matter
almost none of them are 4.2 gpas
the average gpa among millionaires is
about a 3.0
turns out
these are they're very bright i mean
they're not dumb people
but they're not
un they don't have an uncanny brilliance
they're just steady
and follow a process
that's it
all the mythology that's out there
running around
with these wealth inequality morons
and these people that are morons that
want socialism to come in because they
feel entitled to other people's money
instead of going and getting their own
and then they spread a lie that the
american dream is so broken that you
cannot exist in this country today in
the current environment of cultural
meltdown
and build wealth and the answer is yes
you can regardless of
your color your sex your region
regardless of
your
income
you can get there
you can get there now different people
have harder time than others they have
more things to overcome yes racism is
real yes sexism is real
yes regionalism is real
there's a lot of areas of the country
that um especially in a more rural
environment that you move into that not
being you ain't from around here are you
boy it works against you
you get a weird accent
a southerner living in manhattan as an
example
works against you
because some people in the north are so
stupid that they think a southern accent
means a lack of intelligence
and there's people in the south that are
so stupid that they think that
all folks with a northern accent are
mean and angry and
crooks or whatever you know it's just
it's ridiculous so yeah all of that
stuff are it all that stuff is in the
soup all that stuff is and the negative
things are there the only difference is
all of us exist in that exact same thing
some of us with a different starting
line than others but we all have the
same finish line
and the finish line is did you get to
a million dollar net worth or not that's
what we want to know dave is with us
dave is in chicago hi dave what's your
net worth
hey dave it's 1.07 million dollars good
for you just over the line baby how old
are you
last year i'm 46. good for you well done
give me a little break down on your
million dollar net worth so it's about
800 uh between iras and roths
60 60 in a taxable brokerage
170 in a paid off house
and 40 in savings cool cool
and how much of this did you inherit
uh if i could say less than zero i would
zero i had a negative inheritance
i'll take it all right your range of
income in your working life best year
worst year household income
um worst year first year out of college
about 21k
uh best year a couple years ago with
some bonuses about 200. good for you
what do you do for a living
i lead operations for an electronics
manufacturing company what was your
degree in
liberal arts actually okay good what was
your what was your gpa
i like you
i finished around 2.9 and i'm still not
happy about it
that story's gotten around huh
yeah
i like it
well congratulations dave all right what
advice would you have for the younger
version of you
um you know a lot of the same things
that you've been saying
being an adult is not a license to buy
whatever you want or whatever you think
you can afford you know live on less
than you make
and start investing early my 20s was
littered with stupid and uh
and one of the things i did though was
from the first time it was offered i
started putting 10 percent in 401k and
you don't miss it no you don't miss it
when you're investing when you're
investing it um
and so and also um i do believe the lord
loves a cheerful giver and that's always
been a big a big focus of what i've done
um
through for many years yeah perfect well
done dave congratulations jeff is in
dallas jeff what's your net worth
about 2.5 million cool
and you're how old
uh 57. cool give me a little break down
on that two and a half million uh it's
about 1.8 in a 401k private sharing a
couple hundred in roth in cash and then
the rest is real estate
okay so like a million dollars in real
estate
about 500 000. no i missed that okay
you're right 500 okay i got it okay cool
and your how much of this [ __ ] did you
inherit
uh none of it zero okay and your range
of income best year and worst year
uh probably household income worse here
is maybe about 30 up to about 170. cool
what do you do for a living
i am a software engineer another
software engineer they're everywhere
okay cool good your degree in computer
science or what
uh it was actually information systems
information yeah okay all right cool and
your gpa
oh right around 3.5 wow good for you
congratulations sir thank you for
sharing your numbers with us and your
story absolutely incredible okay so we
got a 1 million 3.5 1.4 2.2 1.07 and 2.5
million dollars that we talked to today
35 years old 59 48 56
46 and 57 zero of them were
millionaires because of inheritance uh
they were in business in computer
computer liberal art i don't know i'm
sorry that was their degrees let's see
here
engineering sales software engineer i.t
manager electro ops for an electronics
company another software engineer those
were the degr the career fields gpa's
two and a half was the low up to a 3.85
as the high across them
so this is a fairly standard and we
don't set these calls up i mean we we
invite people to leave a message and
kelly can call them back but we don't
select calls that fit our agenda
anyone that has a million dollar net
worth can call we actually had a guy
call in that won the lottery one time
and i don't care where you got your
million dollars i want to represent what
is really what we really found in the
study was people just like these
this is the typical millionaire
and they were from 35 years old 35 59 48
56 and 46 and 57 years old
so there wasn't any
uh ancient
i'm 80 years old i finally got there and
never took a vacation and i never had a
life you didn't hear them say that
they were 35 years old up to 59 years
old not even any in their 60s
these are very typical millionaires in
america today which means you can do
this people the book is baby steps
millionaires if you want to know how
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]